[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de w y
paie avec deux invités exceptionnels de
delmas et à bonjour bonjour est le
directeur de la scène nationale de saint
quentin et roland lehoucq bonjour deux
astrophysiciens vous êtes au cea de
saclay alors pourquoi tous les deux
parce qu'on va parler de du festival non
pas du festival des rencontres in cité
qui auront lieu du 18 au 26 mars
prochain alors peut-être la première
question vous qu'est ce que c'est que
cette personne rencontrée une cité je
veux dire festival à tout prix non non
ça va être des rencontres écoutez la
genèse est assez simple c'est un premier
constat que les artistes sont de plus en
plus nombreux à s'intéresser aux
questions scientifiques à comprendre les
questions scientifiques comme des points
de départ ou comme la thématique de leur
de leur travail
il y a me semble-t-il en tout cas c'est
sensible une curiosité de plus en plus
importante des publics du big four c'est
pour ces questions là comme s'il y avait
un besoin de plus en plus pressant de
comprendre la complexité de notre monde
on trouve en tout cas ce qu'on nous vend
comme une complexité du monde est-il
aussi complexe que ça et puis à la
situation géographique du théâtre qui se
trouve à deux pas du plateau de saclay
qui est oui quant à saclay il ya le lien
entre deux territoires allant franchit
allègrement laterrière départementale
on peut pas un théâtre ne peut pas
ignorer sa l'environnement donc le
projet d'un théâtre s'inscrit aussi dans
un environnement il est clair que la
présence du plateau de saclay est
importante parce que c'est 15 ou 20 % de
la recherche publique de la recherche
privée en france dont comment est-ce que
toute cette pensée qui existe sur ce
territoire peut peut se relier avec le
théâtre est ce qu'il ya un lien entre le
geste artistique et et la pensée
recherche scientifique et la recherche
scientifique et la pensée scientifique
c'est un peu tout les voilà toutes les
données de l'équation à partir de l'aide
de ces données nous avons construit ses
rencontres ses premières rencontres
alors on va parler du thème qui sera le
thème général qui est le temps mais à un
mot à holon l'eau que vous êtes un
chercheur alors c'est vrai que vous avez
collaboré à des revues grand public mais
c'est très important pour quelqu'un
comme ça quelqu'un qui est un chercheur
qui dans son laboratoire on suppose
occupés par des problèmes très important
d'aller communiqué ce qu'on sait où est
ce qu'on peut communiquer au public sur
blessure c'est très important ça fait
partie des missions du ceva d'abord du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives et ensuite même en
tant que chercheur je penserai partie
des missions des chercheurs même si tout
le monde n'a pas envie de tous les
chercheurs n'ont pas envie non pas
forcément le talent le temps aussi de
faire sa communication scientifique
c'est diffusion des connaissances
scientifiques
à mon sens ça fait partie des missions
que moi j'attribue un chercheur
et donc quand lionel masséna est venu me
voir pour qu'on discute un peu du thème
de ces rencontres est que le thème était
le temps évidemment un sujet fétiche
important en physique et bien j'ai tout
de suite été d'accord pour trouver un
autre moyen il n'est dans un autre cadre
a finalement le cadre d'un théâtre de
parler de parler de physique de
fantaisie du temps évidemment accessible
au grand public
il faut que ce soit sinon si c'est pour
être pour être annoncés incompréhensible
c'est très facile à faire et ça n'a
aucun intérêt évidemment vous verrez
c'est dans ta laboratoire avait des gens
qui vous comprendre on fait ça très bien
entre nous donc le thème le ton il ya
cité une phrase qui est assez connu de
saint-augustin qui dit pas quand on me
demande si on me demande pas ce qu'elle
temps je sais si on me le demande je
suis incapable de répondre
pourquoi pourquoi ce thème du temps
parce que c'est vous qui m'avez des 6-17
est en panne oui mais pas avec formulée
je n'ai pas décidé au départ tel qu'il
est formulé danser dans ces rencontres
déjà vu une approche de la question du
temps alors d'abord pourquoi le thème du
temps parce que je pense que c'est là
que s'inscrit c'est le croisement de
tous ne sait malheureusement de tout et
puis c'est là que s'inscrivent aussi nos
vies et ces notions que de laquelle
j'avais une approche va dire
sociologique en quelques en quelque
sorte après une lecture d'un d'un essai
de hartmut rosa
il parlait de là d'une sorte d'
accélération du temps je me suis donc je
me suis reconnu dans cette sorte d'
accélération du temps j'ai donc
construit voilà tout un tout un tout un
tout un schéma de ce que pourraient être
ces premières rencontres et je suis allé
rencontrer
etienne klein qui est qui physicien
petit anglais fait qu'il sera présent
qui sera présent cazères en garde lors
de ces rencontres et qui était un
collègue de roland et je lui ai présenté
mon projet m'a dit votre projet est très
très bien mais alors des projets comme
celle des années 50 si vous voulez
parler du temps vous avez le cea qui à
côté vous avez saclay qui à côté faut
l'aborder
du point de vue de la science physique
est là nous voilà gros jour la
sociologie la philosophie nous voilà
sachant qu'il y a pas d'incompatibilité
en or mais il ya une porte d'entrée qui
lui semblait en tout cas plus
intéressante qui était la science
physique quitte ensuite à étendre cette
cette thématique à d'autres disciplines
scientifiques donc voilà gros jean comme
devant
puisqu il a abordé la question du temps
par la science physique ça veut dire
parler de la relativité et là je suis
très très embêté 8e clame me dis n'ayez
aucun souci et calais voilà il ya
quelqu'un qui est là et qui va vous
sortez de cette panade c'est roland
lehoucq que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai
contacté dans la foulée qui m'a répondu
très habile très rapidement et qui nous
a guidés tel guide qui sera je pense que
sans lui ces rencontres n'existerait pas
parce que hills a aidé à cerner cette
thématique fort fort complexe et
l'effort abstraite pour la rendre
beaucoup plus concrète et puis pour
l'aborder de façon assez originale peu
détournera l'occasion d'en parler tout
je cite quelques noms donc il ya etienne
klein dont vous parliez alexei grinbaum
denis savoie beaucoup d'autres
scientifiques qui sont la plupart du
sénat la plupart mais pas tous denis
savoir par exemple l'huile et directeur
scientifique au palais de la découverte
il est historien des sciences
guillaume lecointre hui et biologiste et
puis francis eustache il est travaillant
les sciences cognitives sur la mémoire
donc effectivement le la porte d'entrée
que j'allais à etienne klein était tout
à fait évidemment pertinente
on ne peut pas dire des choses sur le
temps sans se mettre au courant un
minimum de ce que la physique en dit
parce que la vision du temps que les
physiciens ont bâti a beaucoup évolué et
surtout c'est très très récemment encore
et ce surtout très éloigné de la
perception commune que nous avons du
temps et donc si on fait de la
philosophie de la sociologie de
l'histoire des sciences ou dieu sait
quoi on ne peut pas ignorer ce que les
physiciens dit sur le temps en même
temps il ya aussi le temps persuasion le
temps subjectif on pourrait dire qui lui
aussi a eu des a été extrêmement étudié
par les sciences cognitives et notamment
par les uns qui travaillent sur le
cerveau et la mémoire et d'où la
présence de francis eustache qui
travaillent à l'inserm et qui est un
grand spécialiste de la mémoire et qui
montre à quel point il y a un lien très
fort entre eux notre capacité à se
projeter dans le futur et la mémoire que
nous avons dû passer et que perdre la
mémoire du passé au sens physique n'est
pas oublié ce n'est pas un oubli
simplement c'est une malformation des
formations et un endommagement des de la
mémoire du cerveau à d à d une amnésie
ad a des conséquences très forte sur
votre perception du temps et sur votre
capacité à vous projeter dans le futur
alors denis savoie comme historien des
chances nous expliquera par exemple
comment on a fait pour mesurer le temps
au fil des âges et ces mesures du temps
ont eu des conséquences évidemment
social très directe puisque une des
premières mesures du temps ça ne serait
ce que pour l'agriculture
être capable de se repérer dans le temps
en temps lors de la saison et c'est pour
les religions pour les impôts c'est
important de savoir les dates précises
les impôts doivent ces mesures du temps
est extrêmement importante pour régler
la vie sociale et en même temps
l'amélioration de la mesure des mesures
du temps ont permis de comprendre des
nouveaux phénomènes physiques qui était
auparavant imperceptible faute d'avoir
les instruments de mesure temporel
approprié on a peut-être un mot quand
même sur ce qui va se passer pendant ces
rencontres
ce soit alors des rencontres avec des
scientifiques naturellement et puis
aussi d un côté spectacle eu une dizaine
de rendez vous avec des scientifiques là
on a voulu et c'est aussi grâce à grâce
à roland qui nous a mis en contact avec
tous ces scientifiques en avait un
on avait un casting idéal et bien le
casting idéal et il réunit pendant cette
semaine la une dizaine de conférenciers
de conférence 4 spectacles une dizaine
de représentations là aussi liés plus ou
moins parce qu'on a voulu
grosso modo contextualiser
contextualisés par dans le geste
artistique par la présence des
scientifiques
donc on oppose la l'objectivité ou la
pseudo objectivité de la science à la
subjectivité artistique ce qui me semble
très intéressant et puis il va y avoir
une partie cinématographique rolland
étant est un grand cinéphile
oui on va avoir un partenariat appelé
cellino science fiction notamment
on va avoir un partenariat avec l'ugc
qui est juste à côté du théâtre et que
je remercie également et on se rend
compte dès qu'on parle de cinéma que
finalement le cinéma s'est intéressé
bien plus tôt que le spectacle vivant
aux questions scientifiques on va dire
dès le départ donc on va marcher sur ces
trois sur ces simples pour le cinéma
mais non bah c'est plus naturel de la
gueule ils veulent mettre une image en
mouvement ils veulent créer du temps
dans une image qui serait d'habitude une
photographie qui est statique et donc la
succession des images d'une illusion du
passage du temps et du mouvement le
temps une première compréhension du
passage du temps c'est le mouvement et
donc ils ont tout le problème de fond
veut recréer le mouvement apparent alors
que ce ne sont qu'une succession d'image
comment on fait donc la question du
temps au cinéma est absolument
fondamentale et fondatrice même du
cinéma alors avoir regardé je crois deux
experts des deux extraits de spectacles
ou encore prévoir que vous pouvez
peut-être les commenter je vais
commenter
[Musique]
alors c'est nous
j'ai à dire une recréation patine
création de la face cachée de la lune
dark side of the moon des pink floyd
album qui a été enregistré avec les
bidouilles des instruments est quasiment
impossible de jouer en live les pink
floyd ne les ont jamais d'ailleurs joué
en live en live il a le travail qu'a
fait thierry balasse avec la compagnie
louis c'est d'abord un travail de
recherche un travail de recherche sur
l'instrumentarium qui avaient été été
utilisé par les championnes en studio et
puis la recréation a créé en live de
l'album studio qui n'a jamais été jouée
tel quel en live c'est fascinant
totalement avec bien entendu de le
célèbre bonnet le tube de saer séné
album on entend un le deuxième deuxième
extrait que vous pouvez commenter
peut-être oui ça c'est le bien nommé
tenir le temps du chorégraphe rachid
ouramdane ça me fait dire que dans un
spectacle on y voit ce que l'on veut les
voir je suis pas sûr que rachid
ouramdane ce soit
ce soit nourri de toutes concernent la
théorie de la relativité de l'histoire
du temps tout cas c'est ce que je voyais
dans ce spectacle c'est pas si du voisin
dans la salle vallier la même chose
c'était une sorte de figuration de chez
paul de cet univers en expansion
de ces choses qui tourne qui s'étendent
ces dix stands
voilà c'est un moment de rêve
ce qui me plaît beaucoup et qui j'espère
fera beaucoup publie donc c'est ça yahia
il ya la partie artistique voilà qu'il
traite aussi de cette question du temps
qui vous dit être sensible par exemple
ce que font les artistes sur ce thème
moi je ne connais pas les spectacles
hérésie il gisait dans ce cadre visent à
découvrir pendant les rencontres
mais moi j'ai juste senti effectivement
l usage à usage de dison de des supports
de l'imaginaire des supports artistiques
pour parler de sciences et pour
pratiquer les sciences à dire que les
sciences on peut les pratiquer au
quotidien comme un chercheur ou comme un
étudiant scientifiques qu'ils soient en
lice et quand ça commence à être un peu
sérieux ou à l'université ensuite ou
alors on peut aussi comme je le fais
bien volontiers en quand je fais des
conférences utiliser ces supports de
l'imaginaire les films de science
fiction par exemple aussi la bande
dessinée éventuellement certaines
oeuvres d'art pour parler de sciences et
montrer que comme disait lionel on y
voit que ce que vont bien y voir mais
parfois les artistes parfois les
réalisateurs de films d auteur de
science fiction s'inspire de la science
vraiment je pioche est parfois la
science a rejoint la science-fiction
j'aimerais bien voir au palais avec vous
merci merci en tout cas à tous les deux
alors je rappelle que ce sont donc les
rencontres une cité du 18 au 26 mars
principalement au théâtre de saint
quentin mais aussi à l'ugc avec des
projections de films merci beaucoup de
masse et à merci beaucoup
roland ciel merci
[Musique]